toi tu mannonces ça comme ça tu veux me
quitter mais quoi ça plus quand il a que
l'usine tu sais très bien que c'est faux
il y a pas que l'usine regarde autour de
toi ça continue comme ça tu vas tout
perd croire oh tuas vu l'heure
qu'est- tuas tu veux baiser non pas
baiser je ve bosser ah non non tu fais
bosser mon sex VO attendez
attende ça notre producteur la seule
chose qui vous demande c'est de remettre
le scénario tel qu'il était il y a 6
mois quand ils l'ont validé sinon ils se
retirent du projet je change pas une
ligne du scénario ça représente combien
votre raort 1 million d'euros do
rejoindre les producteurs au restaant
non j'en rien à fout de manger avec les
producteurs on va pas se faire encore un
gastron avec deux têtes de cul tu
trouves super là tu trouves crédible un
ouvrier ben carrément à fond mais non il
est nul il on fait des caisses pour
faire vrai c'est
ridicule tu es obligé de crier tout le
temps mais bien sûr mais tu as
raison 1000 fois le principal financier
du film nous a lâché il faut demander à
l'équipe de terminer sans être payé et
alors qu'est-ce que je dis à l'équipe
bah tu dis rien tu fais tu tournes tu
fais comme si tout tout va bien tu
tournes ton film comment ça va les
techniciens sont
énervés les acteurs font n'importe quoi
une grande vedette bravo mais tu surtout
un énorme fils de
je me dis que je suis un peu comme
mon personnage principal je suis un
capitaine d'un bateau à la dérive mais
il pleut les gars il ple mais
vous faites tout
chier porte mon projet comme un fardeau
et je me sens
seul tu as trouvé un repreneur non pas
encore pourquoi au pire j'ai un groupe
de médias du Qatar du Qatar mais c'est
quoi cette histoire encore c'est vrai
cette fois-ci attends comment ça c'était
pas vrai
[Musique]
l'autre